[Musique]
c'est comme une boîte à outils où les
personnes peuvent venir ben bas à
prendre approfondir et comme c'est
ouvert et qui a toujours des
professionnels qui sont présents je peux
venir tous les jours si je veux je peux
avoir quelqu'un qui va m'aider à
construire mon cv ou à répondre à une
question qui va répondre à une question
tous les métiers sont impactés en fait
par part du coup le numérique et par
rapport au contexte c'est sûr que
certains secteurs d'activité comme la
restauration par exemple il ya des gens
qui se disent bon ben je
il faut que j'anticipe il faut que je
change on a eu aussi des personnels de
santé qui sont venus nous voir pour
changer
il ya des jeunes louis qui démarra
cursus et qui se posent des questions
donc on peut changer de voie et
construire un nouveau projet on s'est
dit qu'on allait faire une montée une
après midi spécial orientations pour les
jeunes du coup les parents vont pouvoir
venir avec leur avec leurs jeunes
rencontrer des professionnels
donc on a cinq professionnels qui seront
là c'est le 17 mars
mercredi 17 mars de 14h à 17h